okay another story I want to mention
briefly daily wire reports average math
and reading test scores for 13 year olds
the United States hit the lowest level
in decades according to a recent
National long-term Trend assessment
released on Wednesday the national
assessment of educational progress uh
reported the declining education levels
occurred during the pandemic however the
downward trajectory began at least a
decade before government officials and
school districts shuttered classroom
doors and switched to online learning in
response to covid
um so this is that that's why it's
really important when you hear about all
these disastrous outcomes in the public
school system and test scores are
declining and it's just every week
there's another report just like this
and very often they try to blame it all
on the pandemic which to begin with
that's wrong because the pandemic didn't
do any of this okay there's nothing that
happened in the pandemic that would
prevent kids from learning to read okay
the the the covid didn't do that it was
the government's response to covid that
did that
but even that is not the explanation
because all of these Trends the decline
in uh performance
among kids in grade school has that
that's that's that's a trend that dates
back the years and years and years it
accelerated during the pandemic I mean
we shut down all the uh the schools and
crucially you shut down the schools and
then try to replace the schools with
online with zoom
now if you shut down the schools and
then everybody goes into a homeschool
environment well then the kids end up
you know educationally they end up
better because the the education you get
in homeschool is far is far superior to
what they get in public school that's
not what happened for a lot of these
kids
you know it's not like they seamlessly
went from uh public schools are shut
down and now they're being homeschooled
uh no they went from that to all of that
is being replaced by the screen you know
by Zoom meetings basically
um
and that had the effect of accelerating
all these Trends but these were trends
that were in place long before that
and if we were a culture that
um
if we were a serious culture
in any way
this would be
a huge scandal
you know that we would that we would be
talking about and focusing on
and the Scandal being the total failure
of the education system to do the one
thing it's supposed to do which is to
educate the next generation of Americans
it is completely failing in that regard
it's a special kind of company to want
to partner with my show I say a lot of
things that make a lot of people angry
as you probably noticed and this tends
to scare off advertisers that's why I'm
so grateful to Partners like pure talk
who stand behind me and my show no
matter the consequences they might face
Pure Talk shares my values which is why
we've made them the official cell phone
wireless partner of the daily wire
that's not the only reason Pure Talk
offers the most Dependable 5G Network in
the US I use it myself their plans are
top tier but at a fraction of the cost
of ATT Verizon or T-Mobile you get
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
with a mobile hotspot for just 55 a
month you vote how you spend your money
so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you instead
go to puretalk.com Welsh you'll get
great coverage and save while you're
doing it when you go to puretalk.com
Welsh you'll save an additional 50 off
your first month because they actually
value you that's puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans the
one year anniversary of Roe versus Wade
being overturned is coming up and since
then the left has absolutely lost their
minds pro-life efforts which are more
important now than ever are booming you
heard that right despite the narrative
pro-lifers actually are not going away
they have increased in number four days
for life is changing hearts and Minds in
the most blue pro-abortion states in the
country they've had a record number of
locations since Roe was overturned they
grew in both volunteers and locations
with about 1 million Volunteers in 1500
cities they hold peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities this success has
come with new unwanted attention as
you'd imagine from the federal
government and the doj in regards to
free speech as one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one is in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in each state
in a post role America you can help them
fight the ongoing legal battles of
protecting free speech for their
volunteers including Mark the 40 Days
for Life volunteer who had his house
raided by the the FBI helped them defend
free speech by giving a tax-deductible
gift of any amount at 40daysforlife.com
that's 40daysforlife.com
every time we see one of these uh man
dumb guy on the street interviews and
someone's out on a college campus or
they're just out in a street corner
somewhere and they're talking to random
young adults who are walking by and
asking them who was the first president
United States or you know can you name
four states in our country you know how
many continents are on the globe and
they're being stumped by that and we all
kind of laugh about it
um and it it makes sense to laugh
because it's absurd but at the same time
that again is it it's it's it's a
tragedy actually it's a testament to the
fact that our education system has
completely failed
um
and yet we basically yeah this is
something that every once in a while
people look over at it and they say oh
well that's that's a problem that's
unfortunate
but then nothing has ever done about it
you know it's just like the the this sex
abuse epidemic in public schools
that's been going on for years
the the Department of Education like
20 years ago did a report
showing that sex abuse in public school
by public school staff members is is an
epidemic it's like thousands of cases of
it
and it's even 20 years ago the
Department of Education emitted that
and we see the stories that come up
we're all we're all familiar with these
kinds of stories Public School teachers
uh being arrested for child porn or
abusing their students
and yeah people pretend to care about it
and we and anytime we hear a news story
or new Scandal we glance over at it
and then we just get back to whatever we
were doing
and I think the reason is that uh our
society doesn't want to face the total
collapse of the education system
uh and what a disaster has been for
children a disaster in pretty much every
way imaginable we don't want to face
that because of the implications because
of what it means
and what it means individually for a lot
of parents is that
if if if you in any way can you should
be pulling your kids out of that system
well but if I if you do that then that's
like major sacrifices you have to make
in your life you have to completely
restructure your life
because modern societies basically
structured all structured around public
school system
around this uh this idea that you
put your kids on the bus at 7 30 in the
morning they're gone uh and that's
they've got daycare Public Schools
glorified daycare system and then they
come back at four o'clock
and you've got all that time in between
to do what you want to go to work and
our society whole society is kind of
structured around that
if you take public school out it becomes
uh it's you have to drastically change
the way that you do things make some
major sacrifices
people don't want to do that so instead
we we kind of we look away and we let
the public school off the hook
which we have to stop doing thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt wall show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts